[Música]
cómo es que hervían vi y über pudieron
ser líderes de sus industrias sin tener
un auto ni un departamento en su poder
lo hicieron creando confianza entre la
gente
y si nos ponemos a pensar muchas de las
empresas más importantes de nuestros
días se basan en eso se basan en
construir economías colaborativas usando
la reputación de las personas pero hay
un problema que es que ellos se quedan
con nuestra información
por eso va a cambiar porque hace unos 10
años de la mano de bitcoin nació el
primer registro el primer libro hija que
hable en el cual no solamente podemos
registrar transferencias de dinero sino
que podemos registrar todas las cosas
que nosotros hacemos en nuestra vida
igual que con las calificaciones de über
pero con la diferencia que nosotros
estamos en control
con ese registro vamos a poder construir
nuestra vida block change
y con esa vida block sing vamos a poder
interactuar con cualquier persona del
planeta vamos a poder construir nuestras
propias economías colaborativas y va a
ser el inicio del fin de las fronteras
va a dar nacimiento a una nación
realmente global a una nación humana así
que los invito volver a reunirnos y
poder compartir nuestra vida blogs en
una vida sin fronteras sin límites y con
muchas oportunidades gracias
[Música]